- This is really good.
- Yeah, it's actually really good
which is kind of, I'm questioning
everything I've ever known
about my life.
(whooshes)
(Squeaks)
(upbeat music)
- Ice cream is the
perfect desert for summer
because it can be dressed
down, it can be dressed up.
You get crazy toppings like.
- That's very true.
- Literally everything you could want,
you can do with ice cream.
- A variety of stores will just like have,
throw in a bunch of random toppings,
just like really cool to
try new things with it
because it's such a old standard.
(intense music)
- Not bad,
- That tastes really good.
- That's Guinness, yep.
- I don't hate it.
- Yeah I don't hate it
either it's like not bad.
- It's like a root bear float
but for people who drink.
- Guinness is a stout which has
like chocolate and coffee in it,
- Mm-hmm.
- So it's already like a natural,
it makes sense.
- This is the stuff you sell
at your house parties in college,
Yeah son, and we had beer floats
'cause it's super hot outside.
- Come through homies we got
jello shots and beer floats.
- Come for bikinis and dollars.
- And hot chicks.
(laughs)
- Its another brown liquid.
- It looks kind of sticky.
- Yum.
- It's butterscotchy.
- That's like a melted butterscotch candy.
- Yeah.
- Like grandma's house.
- That's very salty.
- It's so sweet.
- Too salty for you?
- Yeah it tastes salty to me.
- Yeah I'm into this
salty/savory combination.
- What?
- No!
- No.
Now I taste it but with the ice cream.
- Oh with the ice, yeah, when
you don't know what it is,
you have no idea.
- It tastes like not that bad.
- You like it.
- If somebody gives me a soy
sauce and vanilla ice cream
I'll take it.
- I'm gonna tell you what I think it is,
you tell me what you think it is.
- Okay ready?
- Three, two, one.
- Olive oil.
- Egg.
- It tastes like banana.
- It's like herby.
- Is it
olive oil?
(gasps)
- Yeah.
- I feel like this could
be an Italian treat like,
- It's good.
- See my general assumption
of life is that olive oil
makes everything better.
I feel like this is just
kind of neutral though.
This is definitely hot sauce.
- I love spicy foods so
bong app the teeth.
- Yeah.
Here we go.
- It's not bad.
- Tastes like hot wings
like desert.
- Tastes like corn.
- That's really good.
- That's good.
- I cannot handle spice at all
but because it has the milk aspect with it
like immediately coats your
tongue and you just get like
the happy feeling of spice
and not the like painful
I wish that I was in a
pool right now spice.
- Beyonce's all like I
got hot sauce in my bag,
we got hot sauce in our ice cream.
(laughs)
You know.
Swag.
- I think at the end of the day we learned
that everything goes well with ice cream.
- I might be open to
trying other things now.
- I would not be surprised
if one of these broke out
and became the next big thing.
The olive oil.
- Or the beer one.
- The beer.
- I feel like the beer one could be a hit.
I could eat that.
- Yeah.
Maybe we should start a business.
- I want to do this to my friends.
I want to trick them so bad.
I gotta get that soy sauce on there
and everyone's gonna eat it and be like
this is so good what was that?
I'm gonna be like soy sauce
and they're gonna blow their minds.
(hip hop music)
(whooshes)
(squeaks)